[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
France 24 Mi nombre es Luis Muñoz el
Papa Francisco cumple este 13 de marzo
su décimo aniversario como máximo
representante del catolicismo el sumo
pontífice llegó al poder con un espíritu
reformista para enfrentar algunos de los
desafíos más importantes que ha tenido
la Iglesia Católica en las últimas
décadas como la pederastia la
modernización de la institución o la
pérdida de fieles en Latinoamérica
reformas que han llegado de manera
parcial en este tiempo pero que también
ha suscitado numerosas críticas la
designación de Jorge Mario bergoglio
como papa rompió con los esquemas de los
últimos siglos En este cargo ya que fue
el primer pontífice en la historia en
ser latinoamericano y en pertenecer a la
congregación de los jesuitas además
Francisco también fue el primer papa que
convivió con su antecesor debido a la
Revolucionaria decisión de beck-nedicto
XVI de renunciar a su cargo que hasta la
fecha era vitalicio su elección no fue
casual Francisco provenía del mayor
bastión de Católicos en el mundo y lo
hacía en un momento en el que la pérdida
de fieles en Latinoamérica era
preocupante además su vocación
reformista fue escogida para afrontar un
momento en el que la iglesia demandaba
cambios urgentes
Francisco llegó desde un comienzo con un
discurso crítico hacia las élites
eclesiásticas y sus comodidades desde su
etapa de sacerdote en Argentina
bergoglio se caracterizó por tener un
marcado carácter social en el que una de
sus banderas era la defensa de los
pobres y de las clases sociales más
necesitadas y este discurso se
materializó en la austeridad que impuso
a su llegada a la cúpula del Vaticano al
tener gestos como la renuncia a su casa
oficial y al coche papal
Amén va mal me duele ver a un cura con
un coche último modelo no está bien la
máquina último modelo
esta situación de austeridad fue de la
mano de situaciones límite para millones
de personas en todo el mundo
especialmente de los países más pobres
Francisco ha defendido la necesidad de
los migrantes de huir de sus hogares en
busca de una vida mejor y ha rechazado
las políticas de algunas naciones
europeas y de Estados Unidos de
endurecer los controles fronterizos por
ejemplo uno de sus primeros viajes como
pontífice fue a la isla de la pedusa en
Italia escenario de una de las mayores
crisis migratorias de la historia
reciente
creo que hoy el mundo está sediento de
paz hay guerras migrantes que huyen esta
ola migratoria que viene de Las Guerras
escapando de la muerte intentando
encontrar la vida la migratoria sin
embargo la designación de Francisco y
cercanía a las clases populares no ha
frenado la sangría de creyentes en
América Latina el continente era una de
las prioridades de la Iglesia Católica
frente al crecimiento exponencial de las
iglesias evangélicas que durante las
últimas décadas han captado a millones
de fieles gracias a su labor social en
los barrios marginales y en las cárceles
el objetivo era sacar a los curas de las
grandes Iglesias del centro de las
ciudades y llevarlos a los barrios pero
10 años después la situación parece no
haber cambiado hasta el punto Que varios
países de Centroamérica han dejado de
ser mayoritariamente católicos y Brasil
el gran bastión católico podría dejar de
serlo en la siguiente década Francisco
también ha organizado reformas en el
seno del poder Vaticano durante ocho
años fue el encargado de liderar el
proceso de renovación de la Constitución
pontificia hasta que en marzo de 2022
fue aprobada el sumo pontífice ha
modificado la composición y las
funciones de La curia Romana y ha
emprendido una serie de reforma sin
precedentes en materia de transparencia
económica en el Vaticano cambios que sin
embargo no han sido tan significativos
en otras áreas durante su papado no se
han entendido los llamados para que las
mujeres puedan llegar a ser sacerdotisas
ni se ha aceptado el matrimonio para
homosexuales creyentes además las
posturas del papa en torno al aborto la
eutanasia o el uso de preservativos han
continuado siendo las clásicas del
núcleo más conservador del catolicismo Y
aunque Francisco ha mantenido una
postura de aceptación de la
homosexualidad ha defendido postulados
como el rechazo de lo que llama
adoctrinamiento de género cuando una
persona
que cuando una persona que tiene esta
condición llegue frente a Jesús Jesús
seguramente no le dirá vete porque eres
homosexual no tenía porque sabíamos eso
vale No en los últimos años Francisco ha
centrado la lucha de la Iglesia Católica
en la pederastia llegando al punto de
pedir perdón en nombre de la iglesia y
reconocer errores graves por su parte a
la hora de no iniciar procesos contra
miles de curas y sacerdotes acusados de
abusar a menores en febrero de 2019
Francisco inició una Cumbre anti
pederastia en la que se abordaron
algunos temas nunca antes tratados en la
iglesia como la creación de una comisión
de investigación de estos delitos reglas
para erradicar los abusos sexuales y
castigarlos y procedimientos para
enseñar a los obispos Cómo denunciar sin
embargo las medidas fueron tildadas de
insuficientes por asociaciones de
víctimas
facho un sentido a pelo hago un sentido
llamamiento a la lucha sin cuartel
contra los abusos a menores tanto
sexuales como en otros ámbitos por parte
de todas las autoridades y personas Pues
estamos ante crímenes abominables que
deben ser borrados de la faz de la
tierra
tras la pandemia la salud de bergoglio
comenzó a deteriorarse especialmente en
el plano físico el papa redujo sus
salidas y sus apariciones públicas por
sus problemas de artrosis e intestinales
Y aunque nunca ha descartado retirarse
antes de fallecer Como hizo su
predecesor de momento ha mostrado la
intención de seguir con 86 años
Francisco se acerca al final de su
papado con la incógnita de si sus
intenciones reformistas son solo el
inicio de un nuevo periodo para la
iglesia o un intento tenue de modificar
una institución milenaria con esto
terminamos Pueden seguir más contenidos
como este en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]